alineados para ser grabados por la
prensa estos son algunos de los hombres
que la policía haitiana acusa de
asesinar al presidente job en el móvil
según las autoridades un escuadrón de 28
personas compuesto por 26 colombianos y
dos estadounidenses haitianos llevó a
cabo el asesinato tres de ellos han
muerto en un tiroteo y al menos ocho
siguen prófugos
nosotros capturamos 17 personas de ellos
15 son colombianos
los hemos identificado por medio de sus
pasaportes y tenemos dos ciudadanos
estadounidenses haitianos también
capturados
el ministro de defensa colombiano dijo
que seis de los presuntos asaltantes son
antiguos miembros del ejército
colombiano y que el gobierno está
cooperando con la investigación en el
exterior de la comisaría que alberga a
los sospechosos los lugareños gritaron
consignas de enfado y quemaron varios
coches que se creen que les pertenecían
no es anormal pagar a los extranjeros
para asesinar al presidente esto no
debería volver a ocurrir todos los
haitianos deberían rebelarse moix fue
asesinado en su domicilio privado
durante la madrugada del miércoles y
algunos han acusado a su equipo de
seguridad como personas de inacción la
fiscalía del estado dijo que dos altos
funcionarios de la policía responsables
de la seguridad del presidente serán
interrogados el asesinato ha provocado
una gran confusión a la hora de
determinar el líder legítimo de haití
con dos hombres que reclaman el poder
justo antes de su muerte moix nombró a
ariel henrik como su nuevo primer
ministro pero aún no había tomado
posesión por ello el primer ministro
interino claude joseph asumió el
liderazgo y declaró el estado de
emergencia durante dos semanas
josep se ha comprometido a celebrar
elecciones en septiembre
estaba previsto una medida respaldada
por washington y naciones unidas